hi everyone thank you so much for coming
to hear my talk really happy to wind up
a great few days of some really
interesting talks and so I am going to
be focusing today on some of the stuff
that I talked about on my blog and
specifically a lot of algorithms that
mess up and how that can be interesting
and sometimes even desirable
so I want to start with one example of
an experiment I really love now this is
from Serena booth who did this while she
was a student at Harvard a couple of
years ago and she built this robot and
it's a-you know the robot was is not a
very not very sophisticated in terms of
being very humanoid or anything like
that but it had the ability to drive
around and it had the ability to speak
specifically it had the ability to drive
up to the student dorms at Harvard which
were protected with the security system
protected with a keycard and it would
ask people to let it into the dorms and
you know this was a test of how much
humans would just obey robots I guess
and she found that one the one it came
up to individual people and asked them
about 19 percent of the time people
would just say oh yeah sure here you go
and let the robot into the dorms and
then she did another twist on this
experiment and rather than make a robot
that was way more sophisticated or way
more human-like and or anything like
that she her small twist was to put
cookies in the container on the top and
call it a cookie delivery robot and then
when the robot asked to be led into the
dorm 76%
but they'll let that robot in so this is
a lesson because if she had gone this
route instead if she had made a more
humanoid more sophisticated robot
I think zero percent of people would
have left that robot in and so there's
the lesson here in that when we're
building algorithms that people might
like to work with might like to interact
with you know sophistication is not
required just cookies
so this speaking of charming humans this
is an experiment I did recently where I
wanted to see you know if a computer
could come up with the same sorts of
things that people might find charming
so pick up lines in particular so I
collected a bunch of these and then
wished I hadn't because I'd forgotten
how terrible and like cheesy or just you
know terrible these lines are but I'd
collected them so I say okay I'll just
use I'll use them I'll give them to the
algorithm and see what it comes up with
and I was kind of not really looking
forward to it but then these are the
kinds of lines that the algorithm
started writing and so you can see
there's failure here in a sense like it
did had no clue what it was getting
doing so hey baby you're to be a key
because I can bear your toot or actually
this end those last ones my very
favorite you look like a thing and I
love you
[Music]
so again this is the this is the cookie
bot strategy toward charming humans and
indeed going for perfection in this case
would have been counterproductive and so
I'm gonna be talking about some
imperfections of machine learning
mistakes that they make and why
sometimes they will work out for the
best
so failure one I want to talk about
limited information and so this idea
that the these algorithms specifically
the kind of text generating recurrent
neural networks that I work with they
don't know anything other than what's in
their input data so this experiment I
did really illustrates this so here are
the examples of existing paint colors
that I wanted to try and get an
algorithm to imitate so these are you
know straight from German Williams RGB
values and the names of the colors that
went with them so I gave this so there
is about you know a few thousand of
these that I gave to the neural net is
its input and asked her to try and
imitate these and here are some of the
colors that it came up with
yeah I mean so there are words that were
in its data input data set and there are
words that were not in its input data
set and it did not know to avoid certain
words that are not in its data input
data set all it knew was that there
probably pronounceable and you know this
kind of illustrates to just how hard it
is to sanitize the output of a neural
net like can you possibly think of all
the ways that might slightly misspell a
bad word or an unfortunate one and this
is why a lot of customer service bots
are sticking to scripts here's another
experiment I did these are ice cream
flavors and again these are the ones
that the neural that came up with this
was actually with the help of some
middle-school coders and okay they came
up with the first two rows the bottom
two wrote the bottom row was one I came
up with when I had accidentally
forgotten that I'd had previously
trained the same algorithm on metal
bands and there's a bit of transfer
learning going on there we had quite
forgotten all about this metal history
but coincidentally saint-louis
connection turns out there is a metal
themed ice cream shop that's slated to
open up in st. Louis in a bit so that'll
be exciting but we like this we like
this kind of uncompromising I mean to
that to us humans that's like that's the
cookies like we enjoy those sorts of
things
speaking of cookies here are some cookie
varieties that neural-net came up with
and you know they are
I'll of these of you know hand butter
sacks low fuzzy feats and cannibal bear
wooded nuts so these are again there's
mistakes here these are not this is not
human level performance but I kind of I
kind of want these you know a good plate
of cuff fluff and coffee drops
so failure number two then this is about
surface appearances and how you know if
you look the closer you look at neural
nets output the more you'll realize how
much it didn't really understand at
least these text generating neural nets
I work with and where you can really see
that play out is in generating jokes so
to start out with this is not a neuron
that this is a rules-based program that
had lots of information about you know
different sounds different relationships
between words and meanings and different
formats that you can put things in to
make puns and you can see these are
technically they're they're adequate
they're technically yes
these are puns I wouldn't call them good
but you can see that it did its job as
it was designed to do so on the other
hand now I'm going to show you some of
short jokes that were written by a
neural net instead and here are some of
the things I got I put 43,000 jokes in
there and yeah
how what do you get when you cross a
pirate with a little butter and a
bathroom so the thing is you know these
are jokes aped objects that contain no
actual jokes these are like the jokes
that a seven-year-old might tell or a
younger kid might tell when they're
still trying to figure out how jokes
work and they don't quite get you know
jokes really and so in some ways these
are much worse jokes than the previous
algorithm but in some ways these are
actually much better jokes and then
speaking of improving on the original
through jokes now we get to April Fool's
jokes so these would be pranks that you
would play on people the original data
set they're all kind of you know mean
but these are just weird like you're
playing these
I mean put marbles in the refrigerator
place a pair of pants and shoes in your
ice dispenser notice you're playing
these jokes on yourself and you know you
get and you end up with this kind of
Yoko Ono style performance surrealism
that you're doing on April Fool's Day
and actually I kind of you know like the
pickup lines the surrealism is actually
kind of an improvement on the original I
think I think this is what April Fool's
Day should be so we're moving on to
failure number three and this is the
idea of limited memories so in these
kinds of texts generating recurrent
neural networks most of the text that
you're looking at when you're deciding
what to generate next is a really small
amount of text so here's a recipe
speaking of you know this is a long item
and you can see it we're talking about
surface appearances again this is a
recipe shaped item that when you look
more closely you notice more and more
problems with it and one of the problems
or I mean perhaps it's fortunate that it
does not remember that is this
particular memory is only about 65
characters long so if you draw the
window of how much is looking and we're
going to ignore the long term the small
amount of long-term memory has for now
but most of what information it has is a
window that's about that big so by that
you can see that by the time it gets
even halfway through the directions here
it's forgotten completely that it was
trying to make clam frosting good thing
and it's now going on about this adding
ingredients sort of at random because it
has no clue what it's still trying to do
but on the other hand at least it has
the right idea when it says you should
end up by serving it with pies
okay failure number four and this one
happens all the time - this is the kind
of unfair situation where you train up a
algorithm on some data set and then you
ask it to perform on something that's
actually quite different that it wasn't
prepared for and this happens all the
time and commercial algorithms where
your training data is not the same as
the real-world data or maybe the
situations have changed since you
trained it and so then use watch an
algorithm sort of flail around trying to
deal with this world that it is not
remotely prepared for so I set up an
experiment like this of course on
purpose and I design a trained an
algorithm to classify names as my little
pony' or his metal bands and so I gave
it these lists of Pony names list of
metal bands it learned to tell the
difference between them and it was
pretty good at names that you could very
reliably tell okay that one's kind of
scary oh yeah that one's really fluffy
and one thing that was kind of
interesting this sort of thing I called
the princess effect where any word that
had the name or any name that had the
word princess in it somewhere
ended up being classified as a pony 100%
no matter what even if it was like right
on our princess death or princess
slaughter or something like that still
Pony 100% pony but the nice thing about
this is that you can give it anything
you don't have to give it something
that's either a pony or a medal you can
give it to classify like any word or
name you want as how Pony or how a medal
it is so of course I gave it these Star
Wars characters and so through
sophisticated artificial intelligence
infallible this is a definitive ranking
of these four Star Wars characters as to
how phony or metal they are and so there
you have it but it is surprisingly easy
to put unintentionally put an algorithm
in a situation that it wasn't really
prepared for and actually this next one
was sort of interesting to sort of
puzzle out and I didn't really see it
coming at first and so here's an example
this is application image recognition
and it comes up with a caption it comes
with a tag this happens to be Asher's
vision API but it could be about
anybody's and I gave it this picture
that I took on vacation and it did a
really good job like not only get it get
the sheep it got the hillside but also
knew which specific hills on the Isle of
Skye those were in the background so I
mean that is a really good job but the
next slide is something or the next
picture I'm the version of that I show
this picture I went in and I
photoshopped out every single one of the
Sheep like I even zoomed way in the
background got every pixel that looked
like it might remotely be a sheep and
they're still there in the caption and
they're still there in the tags so like
what's going on like did I miss one way
in the background or is this like is
this homeopathic sheep visit no
remembering sheep that used to be there
and the answer turns out to be a bit
more simple than that it's that this
picture never had sheep in at once and
it's still saying that there's a herd of
sheep grazing there and so it turns out
that this particular algorithm and
actually a lot of them when they see a
green grassy landscape like this they
say that there are sheep grazing there
and so they start basically
hallucinating sheep because
because I think in their training data
they saw a lot of landscapes like this
that had sheep in them and not very many
that didn't have sheep and they have got
managed to get a bit confused as to what
the word sheep actually means and what
problem we were actually trying to get
them to solve and so you know what
happens if this problem is reversed what
I have you know what if there are sheep
that are not in a grassy landscape what
happens so I went to the internet and I
asked them for sheep in unusual places
and I turns out interesting things
happen so if you paint sheep orange
sometimes they will be identified as
flowers if goats climb up into trees
they will be flocks of birds or maybe
giraffes and then if you know you put
them in a car they'll become cats or
dogs or you hold them in your hands they
become cats or dogs again bring them in
your living room
they're also identified as cats and dogs
but if you bring them into a grocery
store somebody gave me a picture of this
then the sheep are invisible like they
don't appear in the caption at all so
this sort of suggests like in your
future cyberpunk surveillance state you
know sheep costumes might be the way to
go about
so back to but if we go back to the
empty fields here's a sheep again in the
fields there may you know this is kind
of a hint that there's also maybe it has
a similar misunderstanding about
rainbows and so you know what this is is
this an algorithm that really didn't it
tried its best but it didn't have a
clear idea of what problem it was
actually specifically trying to solve
and it solved slightly the wrong one and
this kind of thing happens all the time
so shiny shoe today's his presentation
he talked about some tic-tac-toe
algorithms that they were playing
tic-tac-toe against each other and both
of them knew that the best idea is to
let your opponent go first so they just
kept passing and passing and saying well
your turn your turn your turn so yes
that was a solution that wasn't the one
we were looking for another example to
do with image recognition again and this
happened at Stanford a researcher called
Roberta Novoa was training an algorithm
to recognize tumors and from in pictures
of skin cancer and then what he
discovered after he'd trained the
algorithm is that apparently the largest
tumors happened to have rulers next to
them in the picture for scale and so the
algorithm learned to recognize the
rulers instead so this kind of
abstraction is kind of pointing out the
Sheep
this is the Sheep not to field the sheep
that animal this kind of abstraction is
a problem that people are working on but
for now it's kind of fun to enjoy the
antics of confused machine learning
algorithms for example you know what if
they narrated your museum visit and the
rosetta stone becomes a black bag and
you've got you know you pitch paintings
could be just about anything so there's
a lot of fun to be had with these
algorithms too so failure number five
problem is too broad so here's an
example actually of a
generative adversarial network that was
set up for success so it was this is a
project I really like by artist Anna
Riddler who set up this algorithm to
generate pictures of tulips and to make
sure that it would actually do a really
good job she spent an entire spring
collecting ten thousand pictures of
tulips that she took herself in
consistent lighting conditions on the
same sort of camera same background and
everything and came up with this really
uniform dataset that it was easy for the
algorithm to latch on to and Ashley
Krishnan yesterday she showed some
examples of photorealistic celebrity
faces that were generated using this
sort of strategy as well but the and the
algorithms did a really good job because
their job was very limited so in the
case of the tulips generating algorithm
it has no idea what's below the stem and
the celebrity generating algorithm has
no idea that people have bodies or feet
all it knows is this very small chunk of
its data set so that is a recipe for
success and here's a in this next slide
here's a picture from a paper that I
read recently really enjoyed and here's
another algorithm set up with a really
narrow task which was it was supposed to
take a description like the one on the
left and use that to generate a picture
of a bird and this one did a really
really good job and I mean technically
an excellent job the the description did
not specify that had to have a beak
so left that out it doesn't understand
how birds really work but what I really
like about this paper too is that they
here's an example of pretty impressive
success but then with the same group
took the same strategy the same
resources and then they trained it on to
generate pictures not just of birds but
like of everything stop signs people
buildings and all sorts of different
animals
and so if you give that algorithm the
one whose job was really broad the same
description that is supposed to try and
generate a picture of a bird here's the
bird that comes up with instead so I
mean it's really striking strikingly
different level of performance and what
I really like also about this project is
that a guy named Chris Valenzuela set up
an interactive demo using runway and a
self at that URL up on the upper right
that's going to be up for a while
and you can ask it to draw all sorts of
things so for example I could asked it
to draw an image of a girl eating a
large slice of pizza and here is what it
came up with for that so it made some
mistakes it made several in fact
and these turn out to be consistent
mistakes this
you know and in fact you can see if you
ask it to generate a whole bunch of
people you can see that it is
consistently there comes up with the
wrong number of orifices that people
have during your presentation yesterday
Ashley Krishnan pointed out that these
algorithms are generally bad at counting
and and specifically in this case
counting the number of various eyeballs
and things that people have and where
they're located unimportant to this
algorithm the other thing you'll notice
about the this collection of pictures is
that is generating pretty consistently
pale-skinned faces as well so this gives
a hint that as data set probably was
composed of mostly pale faces and maybe
there is a bit of a diversity problem in
this training data set other things as
algorithm does it has a thing for clocks
so if I ask it to generate a picture of
a clock like just one single clock it's
the old boy clocks I love clocks
and I don't know why here's another
thing it does
I was actually really really pleased to
see that but it whenever you ask it for
sheep it doesn't always do this because
you can ask it for sheep in a way that
understands sheep a little bit
differently so if you ask it for a
single sheep but you'll get this instead
so it draws a lump of wool and then it
fills the entire universe out to
infinity with wool - just to be safe so
this algorithm this algorithm that was
asked to do a bit too much it's
struggling it's safe to say it's not
perfect but there are some things that's
good at and there are some things it's a
lot of fun at so creepy surrealism it
can do that really well it can also do
spooky really well as well black and
white portraits yeah there are creepy
portraits it's also very good at again
with the Sheep surrealism involving
sheep it also is really good at drawing
televisions actually whenever you ask it
for a television it gets that pretty
well and then of course the clocks
yeah if you want weird surrealism if you
want anything's filled with spooky
clocks this is your algorithm so next
failure training data the importance of
training data and this is not so much a
failure necessarily as a quirk that pops
up and here's another demo that I really
like and this you can try out at visual
dialogue org so this is an image
recognition algorithm that will generate
a caption and it'll generate and it'll
you can also ask it follow-up questions
you can have a conversation with this
out for them it's so cute and you can
see one of the things we notice about
his data set is it was not trained on
Star Wars but it tries it's best and the
other thing is it was trained to give an
answer no matter what and it turns out
that it doesn't have very many examples
it was trained on examples of humans
asking questions about an image and
humans answering those questions that
other humans asked and so what it learns
is that humans were not really that
confused about the images very law very
often they generally knew what was in
the image even if they didn't know
precisely how to describe it and so what
you get is an algorithm that will Bluff
because it doesn't know that
oh yeah I don't even know what this is a
picture of is actually an answer that it
can give that doesn't see that very
often so if you give it for example this
picture here it'll say oh yes it's a dog
and if you ask follow-up questions about
the dog then it will it'll try its best
to answer these and you know is it round
yeah it's a very round dog interesting
breed
another thing is that it didn't see
boring pictures very often I think so
here's an example a picture of just some
plain rocks and it says oh yeah
elephants these are great you know ten
how many elephants all there's ten
elephants I mean it always thinks it's
on the best Safari ever no matter what
you show up playing grass and it's like
oh boy giraffes and Beyonce said three
drafts and then ten flying saucers and
so what it turns out to be the is that
since it was learning from examples of
answers people gave to questions that
people asked it seems that nobody had
really asked the question how many
giraffes are there when the answer was
zero and so it has learned that the
answer to how many giraffes is it can be
many things but it can't be zero so no
matter what the picture is of if you ask
it how many giraffes there will there
will be at least one giraffe one thing
that it does understand really well as
it turns out is the pictures that the
first algorithm generated at dad
generated so here's the pizza girl again
and it says so yes
human girl eating
no nothing unusual
yeah ordinary girl ordinary cake no and
a two drafts so it turns out algorithms
that were trained on the same data set
share a lot of the same quirks and can
interact in fun ways and so if I give it
you know here's another picture from
that first I'll go from Afghan girl
eating a large slice of cake and we
people okay if we saw the caption we
might be able to kind of guess what it
was going for and what the attempt was
here and but it turns out that there's a
whole bunch of image recognition
algorithms specifically the ones that
were also trained on cocoa this sort of
data set of training images and they all
say oh yes this is a girl eating a piece
of cake sometimes they will disagree
slightly on the details but they're all
very consistent and knowing exactly what
the first algorithm was trying to do on
the other hand other algorithms that
were trained on a different training
data set they have no clue what's going
on here so these ones were all trained
on imagenet and they yeah they're
they're kind of just as puzzled as maybe
many humans would be and so this idea
that you know algorithms can can know
what's going on or they can have these
certain behaviors depending on their
specific training data that shows up a
lot in these things known as adversarial
attacks so here's a picture from recent
paper showing an example of this so you
have the lifeboat on the Left if you
give it a - an image recognition
algorithm it'll know what that is but if
you put this small patch of noise in the
lower right or sometimes it can be some
isolated pixels you can figure out how
to configure that patch noise or how to
configure those pixels such that this
algorithm will be will make a mistake
and it will now think that this lifeboat
is a scotch Terrier instead and so you
know these algorithms can be fooled by
things that look obvious to us
you know just as we're susceptible to
optical illusions they can be
susceptible to designed attacks and so
they just as we see like some kind of
weird monstrosity they see a harmless
human girl eating cake you know we don't
want these things necessarily running
security in our cyberpunk future but you
know so we can imagine kind of fun
things to do with these sorts of
adversarial mix-ups or you can also
imagine it being exploited on medical
images for insurance law fraud there's
been people writing about that recently
saying hey if we can you know change
just a few pixels on these and suddenly
it's being classified in some other way
by whatever gold standard classification
classification algorithm is helping
people make mistake or people make
decisions on what kind of treatment
someone can get this could be very
subtly exploited and unless we have
human experts looking for mistakes we
may not be able to catch it very easily
so there's that side of this whole data
data Sweat work but what I really like
is there's another class of users that I
really like and this is an example of
using this sort of phenomenon for art
instead so this is some work by Tom
white I like this because he's got two
algorithms that are basically playing
off one another he's got one that
generates images and tries to generate
images that another algorithm is going
to identify as some kind of category
like to identify as a cabbage for
example and what he gives the first
algorithm to work with is some really
simple brush strokes and some really
simple washes of color like not complete
freedom but has to work with these with
this very limited palette and so it
comes up with these these really cool
abstract paintings that to us don't look
quite like they're supposed to but two
algorithms that were trained on the same
data set and I think in this case it's
image net
it with really high probability knows
exactly what all of this art is and so I
kind of like this idea of art that's
specifically designed to appeal to other
algorithms and I'm kind of looking
forward to Connor Walsh's bot curity
curated poetry magazine that they
mentioned earlier today like that is
going to be a lot of fun I think and so
this brings me to my next project that I
want to talk about which is what I
called Skynet and this is I called the
perfect school story because this thing
was doomed to failure from the very
start and this was a project in which I
was going to I some knitters put me up
to this and they asked me to try and
train one of these recurrent neural
networks to generate knitting patterns
and so unlike some people here at this
conference I am NOT an expert in textile
art so I don't know nothing about
knitting I've never tried it so that was
one thing that doomed us to failure and
another thing I'll show you I'll show
you an example of a knitting pattern and
this is actually one that skynet
itself generated so if you are a knitter
you'll start to notice some interesting
things about this pattern if you're not
a knitter let me point out that this is
a really tough problem for a it looks
like code basically and basically that's
what it is and it's a really tough
problem for cursive neural net to try
and generate it's like tough like the
recipes because we have this you know if
you have limited memory it's tough
because everything that happens in later
rows depends on things that happened in
earlier rows and we've got limited
information as well because I didn't
know how to help it out by giving it
ideas that it should count stitches or
sort of any sort of framework with which
with which to work so that was a problem
and is also a too broad of a problem
because I had given it not just things
that are
but I had given it round patterns as
well I'd given it lays had given it
ribbing and I'd given it small patterns
and large patterns and so there was a
lot of things in here that might make
this problem really tough and so I at
first didn't know how tough it was or
how badly we may or may not have failed
and so I gave this pattern to that group
on Ravelry and I asked them you know
does does this do anything does this can
anybody knit this and somebody did this
and it's really cool-looking I mean it's
got this it does not look like a human
pattern it's got all this weird you know
non symmetric strangeness to it and then
somebody else knitted the same pattern
and came up with this and so what it
turns out is that these dinners in fact
all the knitters who tried any of things
any of the things Skynet made they were
just debugging the code automatically so
we have an example of a computer that is
generated code for humans to execute and
they do that by debugging the code first
and each each individual knitters
choices when they do bug like what do
you do with for example row six which
doesn't exist like how do you fill that
in you know
do you copy row five do you just skip it
in row sevens now row six what do you do
with the repeats like there's all these
mistakes that they just kind of had to
take and stride and turns out litters
are used to this because a lot of the
patterns that they deal with have
mistakes and in fact they said oh yeah
you know I sort of thought of Skynet as
like maybe an elderly relative was kind
of forgetful and doesn't speak much
English but there's some sense behind it
so but if you don't do very much
debugging then instead of ending up with
patterns like these which are sort of
squares which you can imagine you could
keep going and you can make this into
some kind of strange garment if you
don't do the debugging then you end up
with patterns like this instead
so tentacles you get tentacles and in
fact you know in this next slide here's
an example of this is something that
Skynet called tiny baby whales Soto I
came up with names for all these it's
like really neat strange names for all
of these and tiny weight baby whales
Soto definitely has tentacles and yeah
it was kind of cool but what was
interesting is despite all these
mistakes despite how terrible Skynet's
patterns are and how much help it needed
might the knitters really had fun with
it and they liked how you know the
patterns came out looking cool and
organic okay they complained a bit too
like these patterns like you can't
really get into a rhythm when you're
making them some of them are actually
physically uncomfortable to do because
there's just some of the motions just
they don't flow right and humans would
not have come up with this and that they
started you know referencing terrible
headaches and referencing snow crash and
things like that but you know what they
one of them after switching back to
after having done Skynet projects for a
while they switched back to doing
regular patterns and they said you know
they kind of missed the pigs and the
tentacles and the brain scrambling
so we the Skynet did not remotely
achieve perfection it was doomed from
the start but humans enjoyed it anyways
and now that's not to say that
perfection is always a bad thing like
sometimes we need these these algorithms
to be accurate so self-driving cars
medical imagery Tyrannosaurus detection
things like that it is important that
the algorithms are accurate it is also
important that if we ask them are they
sure they don't Bluff like we we really
want a good probability on things like
this
and you know sometimes the quirks
[Applause]
sometimes the quirks hiding in the data
might be drafts but other times it might
be more serious than that it might be
racial or gender bias and for example
that example we saw of at Gann
generating only really pale skin faces
so there are definitely reasons when we
we need to strive for accuracy we need
to make sure these aren't making
unfortunate or hilarious mistakes but in
other cases you know we just need to we
don't need perfection we just need to
remember how much humans love cookies so
that's my take home message here is that
if you're designing something for humans
like me to interact with like I don't
want perfection I want something that's
fun I want something that's engaging
something that's joyful and that
hilariously is is hilariously wrong so
thanks so much for listening to me there
are more weird experiments on AI
weirdness comm and if you'd like to talk
more about this come find me afterwards
or look me up on social media thank you
all so much for being here
you